[Music]
and that's rude news
Bissell rumor in California come to sip
we have really good drinks by um sip two
locations Westwood and roll that house
thank you very much
we like the subtle approach here
submitted by Nancy from England loves
JK's oh we love you too England
yeah you know Nancy jasc everyone there
do your [ __ ] job
Wow Elon Musk is apologizing after
calling one of the Thai rescuers a pedo
oh why would he do that hey I think I
think that the rescuers say some [ __ ]
about I'll show you you know okay show
me then I want to know Abbi you live
[Music]
all I noticed he made that [ __ ]
little missile for that little kid back
to go through the cave and [ __ ] but it
didn't get you you got [ __ ] missile
ask Dukey imagine being that thing in
your Krampus [ __ ] and it's like all I've
ever die I would die if they said it was
in the 11th hour round trip in a now
that game so imagine sitting there in
the dark and then like what if they drop
it and you fall to the ground and then
it stops moving and an 11 there it was
in and out I mean 11 hour round trip it
just looks like a dildo
I don't know but then what if they threw
like a little iPad for you they give you
iPad
so even though you're you're trapped in
a little thing you you know you have a
little iPad but what if they just drop
you and you hit the ground and then it
stops moving then you die don't go get
you what if they died but people know
you're in there that's the that's the
thing you know yes then you a must he
kept like publicizing like all I just
came out of Cape 3 and like a lot of
people are like oh my god shut up we get
it you're in Thailand trying to help but
then he was saying like well you know a
lot of people ask me like is there
anything I can do so then that's when he
started creating this mini sub which he
said that he was talking to the cave
people and making sure that whatever he
is creating can be usable but like this
diver here one of the experts who was
integral in the rescuing of the boys he
says this
idea in sticky submarine where it hurts
just have absolutely no chance of
working
he had no no conception of what the cave
passage was like the submarine I believe
was about five foot six long rigid so it
wouldn't have gone round corners or
grounds you know around any old
obstacles it wouldn't have made the
first 50 meters into the cave from from
the dive start point just just a PR
stunt leave very quickly the story
should have been why is this such a dick
wife Ellie he's so bitter you want must
some people some people are bitter
because they think it's all for the
limelight yeah and then some people are
like hey man like whether it is or not
we should be encouraging billionaires to
do nice [ __ ] because hey like if you
think about all the other billionaires
out there they're not doing [ __ ] like
this no one else is doing it in it yeah
and even if they are like it's not a lot
of them you know it's an yeah I wouldn't
have thought the reaction was like that
I thought a huge gonna be like well it
just doesn't make sense you know like
this is the reason why but he'd look he
was like yeah that guy he's like well
your fifty million dollar sub wouldn't
even fit anyways they did like that's
not even is like yeah it's almost like
like a billionaire brought over [ __ ]
I don't know like five million gallons
of milk to feed hungry children they're
like well he can stick it up his ass
because it's a PR stunt
the the credit that he's getting for no
help and it's just him coming in it's
kind of like the politician that comes
in and [ __ ] just cuts the ribbon or
digs the [ __ ] first scoop of dirt and
throws it but then there's the guy that
do the real work which is him and maybe
he wanted the recognition
I don't know because those guys are the
real heroes the divers they actually did
the [ __ ] sweat and no one knows their
names no one no one really yes
diver after that he's a diver yeah he
was the key yeah they keep their word he
was like one of the experts that
masterminded the whole rescue Oh dope
yeah she was the guy that was at who
curve vacation in Thailand and he says
what they need divers and he ran out and
obviously I made that I made it a real
though baby no I know I know
so this it's like poker would you like
to read this
okay so heard about Elon Musk's rescue
submarine the cave diver who
masterminded ty cave rescue called it a
PR stunt
that was the Politis thing he said you
might be wondering well he tried to help
let me explain what this thread and this
NYT piece yeah so then Y Allah and
responds with it never saw this British
expat guy who lives in Thailand suss at
any point when we were there in the
caves only people in sight were the Thai
Navy and Army guys who were great Thai
Navy SEALs s corners in total opposite
of wanting us to leave water level is
actually very low and still not flowing
you could literally have swum to cave
five with no gear which is obvious how
the kids got in if not true then I
challenge to do to show final rescue
video huge credit to pump and generate a
team unsung heroes here you know what
don't bother show me the video we will
make one of the mini sub pod Oh we'll
make one of the mini sub pod going all
the way to k5 no problem oh sorry pedo
guy you really did ask for it yeah and
then and then someone ended up saying
like wow that's rude like her uncle for
whatever man I think what is the
responding sent something like oh watch
we'll see it's deleted so I couldn't
what if you did some research on him
like who the [ __ ] is this dude he was
there for a tiny little boy vacation I
bet you okay no I
I don't know I don't know this but then
when I was in when I was in Thailand
Bangkok specifically there were so many
[ __ ] tourists old white dudes with
little last hi girls
you so many [ __ ] holding hands on the
street walking riding scooters together
everywhere and then so we were we were
on the back of a pickup truck just
[ __ ] flipping them off every single
one we were like good job but it was so
neat huh yeah we were just like flipping
them off [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you but it was
like near your church right yeah we were
with my church that's amazing we were
fighting for God right yeah so many
layers to this story because number one
it was a church event and number two
you're also 13 bet you want this [ __ ]
don't you punk [ __ ] yeah we were like
13 14 at a church mission trip and it
wasn't was doing it - it was like a
truck so they have these taxis out there
that are like kind of makeshift taxis
yeah yeah but no they're they're just
pickup trucks and then they put like a
little uh like a cab in the back and
then they weld
bars on the cab - so if you want to hang
off the side you could stand on the
bumper and hang on the bar so Asian so
then yeah not safe at all but they were
letting us kids just [ __ ] hang there
and we would just hang on the bumper and
and just flip people off all day like it
was so awesome obviously yeah now I just
want to go to Thailand and just meet
these guys and just go yuck Yeah right
gross right then just walk away theme up
the rest of the day
yuck yes so then Elan I ended up
tweeting don't judge it unless you've
tried it
they're British expats probably same you
don't know these delicacies
oh so an Elan musk ended up tweeting at
this person who tweeted out like this
whole breakdown of the whole fiasco with
the divert and musk and so he ends up
responding to that tweet saying as this
well read an article suggests my words
were spoken in anger after mr. Unsworth
said several untruths and suggested I
engage in a sexual act with the mini-sub
which had been built as an act of me and
according to specifications from the
dive team leader nonetheless his actions
against me do not justify my actions
against him and for that I apologize to
mr. Unsworth and to the companies I
represent as a leader the fault is mine
and mine alone
there was a four percent drop in Tesla I
would have just been like straight up
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] I'm saving the earth
deal with that signed a check I would
have took the four percent just like a
column a petal all of tesla's investors
were calling out for him to apologize or
else they're gonna pull out oh I see
like you that's why I'll never be a
billionaire with a public company he
doesn't like I don't understand why dick
Pearson he doesn't need PR and the fool
me to [ __ ] flamethrower for people
that's enough PR for everyone
I still want one yeah I do the boring
limp
it was like 800 bucks if you just want a
flame thrower he just sucks because
today we live in a world where actors
politicians and the most powerful and
most popular people you question their
integrity even if one of them is is
doing some charity work for the love of
charity or whatever because just how
much attention they get cameras warm
them and all that even if they want a
low-key do it because there's a lot of
celebs that do it low-key but there's
paparazzi and all these people that come
in and they want to publicize it I'll
walk arrested peace yeah like there's a
word there's not one girl I got
convicted something and Kim Kardashian
paid for her to look like something
awesome she paid for her lawyer fees cuz
this chick I think like oh the little
girl that was you know killed the dude
that rape butters of prostitution yeah
yeah and Kim Kardashian offered to pay
for all the lawyer fees and [ __ ] and
people are like still
on her like after all these years all
the charity you should feel like oh
she's just a [ __ ] video ho [ __ ]
done more that video has a nice ass dare
you
she's helped so many people and Bieber
little celebrities should donate more
they have so much money no matter what
they do
whoever's gonna be like well it's either
a PR stunt or they just couldn't they
could've given more like [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] give $5 so homeless guy in the
corner
there at least have this argument after
the kids are out oh yeah okay after it
suck if the kids are still in there
and then they're just [ __ ] artyom
patty I think while the kids were still
in there people were mad at him for
creating that [ __ ] missile and that's
too soon that's like it's about the kids
let's just get the kids out before he
start pointing fingers and all that
[ __ ] I heard somewhere that the
rescuers actually reached out to Ilan
wants to see if there's anything that he
can do to help - it was fans tweeting at
him I don't know if there was a rescuers
none of those okay yeah I mean whether
whether it's if it's like honest or not
if billionaires are gonna put money
toward help and whatever that [ __ ]
who cares yeah everything I just happen
to hunt is like the scourging probably
yeah it is he brought out batteries to
to like the Tesla batteries to help pump
out the water to like the dude actually
helped and you're talking [ __ ] on him
maybe the [ __ ] sense
I'll come no one tweeted I made it go
hell would you have done gave out free
Uncle Sam water well you can't even go
to the dentist when your teeth are
hurting I don't know like farts reports
response to be like sorry I'm gonna be
busy sip all free Uncle Sam hats and
that's all they need and Jim passes
that's boy we would have brought up
water they're stronger swimmers for next
time I didn't barbell sweaters because
they're cold
[Music]
you
[Music]